- Really, why we love to do what we do is
because it's continuing Dad's legacy,
and his mission to teach
people about animals.
(audience applauds)
- And you're getting
married next year, right?
- Oh, my goodness!
- And at the zoo, right?
- Yes, right at Australia Zoo.
- Congratulations!
(audience applauds)
- Oh, I didn't know!
- So, I mean, are you like,
is he walking you down the aisle,
a koala walking you down
the aisle, what's happening?
- That's a good question, maybe both.
Maybe Robert and a koala
could walk me down the aisle.
- Exactly, we're gonna have
animals involved somehow.
(Bindi laughs)
- Yes, but definitely,
Robert's gonna walk me down the aisle.
- I was so incredibly
touched when Bindi said,
"Robert, would you walk
me down the aisle?"
And yeah, I think, I mean I
know Dad would be so proud
of you, and we all love you so much.
You're achieving so much, so
it's gonna be such an honor,
yeah, to, and Chandler is actually,
he is such a great team member.
He's incredible.
(audience applauds)
- Bindi and Robert's mom Terri,
here in the audience with us.
How exciting!
(audience applauds)
I mean, first of all, I mean, yes,
it's exciting your
daughter's getting married,
but also they're carrying
on what your husband did his whole life.
That's a beautiful thing that
y'all are all still continuing
that and changing lives, exactly
what he would have wanted.
How proud are you?
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, it's very special,
but I do like how a friend
of mine summed up Chandler,
'cause I said to her,
"You know, Chandler is so
kind and loving and respectful
"and loyal to Bindi that
he's the perfect guy."
He doesn't even drink, and
my friend, she said to me--
- Problem A.
- Oh, my gosh!
You have a designated driver for life.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, my God!
- He's perfect!
It's a match made in heaven.
- That's amazing!